what started is I saw an article on BART
barstool sports where Dan cats big cat
from barstool sports was writing about
this I think he's been going after JJ
Watt about social media for a year or so
and Dan joins us now is that how long
this has been going on Dan
it's been a couple years I would say
that I don't know if it's something I
should be proud of but I am the
preeminent JJ Watt social media hater uh
probably on the internet right now what
first bothered you you know I think it's
very tricky you guys had a great
discussion you have to add an element
except self-deprecation into your social
media game you can't be the guy who's
always at the gym I think obviously
Twitter's a cynical place you know you
guys had Jim Nantz on a couple weeks ago
he was talking about the cynicism that's
all over Twitter people don't like
people who are always happy always you
know I woke up this morning and I wanted
to go to the gym and I wanted to save
life people have said not being able to
show that element I think becomes
disingenuous and obviously looks kind of
fake so you did want to go to the gym
and you did want to save lives in that
order is that what you're saying
I never want to go to the gym and I
always say that I never want to go to
the gym so that that helps my social
media goal do you think the JJ Watt
truly believes in what he is sharing
with you as it's real and and you know
it comes from a good place so that
that's really the million-dollar
question here because I do think he's
obviously a very good guy and that's not
what the discussion is we're not saying
JJ was a bad person he's obviously a
very good person the question is does he
think that you know telling everyone for
the perfect example is the Kobe Bryant
game the other night you when he
snapchats at 10:30 at night that he's at
the gym not to make it about himself and
then he points out that he's not making
it about himself and that it's really
Kobe's night even though he was the one
who told us that he was at the gym at
10:30 so it's a very weird dynamic with
him and I I do think that just kind of
showing a little bit of a human side I
don't know where where he can get that
I've actually told him that he should do
a video with me we'll take off
our shirts and put some tires because I
got the fat body and he's obviously in
you know probably has four percent body
fat but something that show the human
side would go a long way for so you've
engaged with him uh how did he respond
we had probably the most
passive-aggressive subtweet off I think
I've ever seen on Twitter uh he was not
even he's not a fan of mine obviously I
with the irony of it all the whole thing
is on the University of Wisconsin grad
so if anyone should like to do what it
should be me um but yeah we're hopefully
we're going to do something you know a
video or something together and I told
them will humanize we humanize people
will show them in a different light but
it's a tricky spot room I also notice
you guys are talking about the sunset
the key for a sunset is you have to use
the black and white filter because
everyone uses filter on sunset so you
take the black and white filter you put
on the sunset you can't see the sunset
that's how you make fun of yourself on
social media mmm seating are you writing
that down
black and white I said I did that I I
stroll nice sunset and I'll make it
black and white never look at magic we
can't even see the sunset that's the
point so maybe that's all JJ what have
to do well he's not and it's unjust JJ
Watt because the more popular you are
the more people are sharing what you put
out on social media if you know DeAndre
Hopkins put something out not many
people are going to be picking that up
the way they do with JJ Watt but it's
like Russell Wilson I think I think
Russell was kind of teetering on the
brink of doing the same thing look I get
it CR is beautiful and you want to share
your pictures but whatever happened to
those pictures being shared by the two
people in the picture and not everybody
else
absolutely Russell Wilson the
distinction I've made Russell Wilson's a
goober and did you watch more of a
trihard so there's that's the line
between them but Paulie and I have
talked about this before and Paulie time
is told told me that he you know the the
Hard Knocks show obviously was kind of a
tipping point because HBO JJ Watts a
star they made the show very much about
him they showed him nonstop and when you
do something like that it's supposed to
be a team sport and it all JJ Watt all
the time people start noticing and they
start you know looking at
differently but it Tebow was doing this
before JJ Watt was where he's robbing
people spunk that's the thing you can't
I mean people stick to football so if if
you're bad at football and you have that
you know issue people looked at people
and they said okay well he's maybe a
little bit of a try-hard but he can't
throw pass so he's not perfect JJ Watt
wants you to believe that he's perfect
and he's perfect on the field and once
you believe these perfect off the field
as well okay which athletes use social
media in the proper way so this is a
little biased because I do consider them
friends but Chris and Kyle Wong I think
are the perfect case they you know crisp
usually goes back and forth with fans
Kyle actually plays video games with
fans I think those guys are very
approachable they're normal and and they
don't take themselves too seriously and
they can make fun of themselves and
that's really what it comes down to is
we want to be able to see athletes we
want to the human side we want to see
you know we know that you have friends
that probably bust your balls from time
to time let us see that let us see you
have a night where you don't go to the
gym and maybe you go to the bar or
something like that let us see a little
bit of that anything on all the way to
the Rob Gronkowski side but there's
somewhere in the middle that people can
you know athletes can reach especially
in this day and age Dan thanks for
joining us keep stirring it up I
appreciate it I appreciate it thanks
guys love the shell tonight it's a big
Kent from bar stools sports the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]